you
everybody is concerned about killer
robots we should ban them you know isn't
doing any research into them it may be
unethical to do so it's a wonderful
paper in fact by a professor at the post
naval graduate school in Monterey a
balut bj's trouser I believe the title
is the moral requirement to deploy
autonomous drones and his basic point in
that is is really pretty straightforward
we have obligations to our military
forces to protect them and things that
we can do which may protect them failure
to do that is itself in an ethical
decision which may cause maybe the wrong
thing to do if you have technologies so
let me give you an interesting scale
that whole thing down to show you this
doesn't have to be about you know
terminator like robots coming in and you
know shooting at people and things like
that think about a land mine now land
mine has a sensor will switch you step
on it it blows up there's a sensor
there's an action that's taken as a
result of a change in its environment
now it's a fairly straightforward matter
to take some artificial intelligence
technologies right off the shelf today
and just put a little camera on that's
not expensive Sam Khan you having your
in your cell phone a little bit of
processing power that could look at
what's actually happening around that
landline and you might think well okay I
can see that the person who is nearby me
is carrying a gun I can see that they're
wearing a military uniform so I'm going
to blow up but if you see it's just some
peasant out in a field with a rake or a
hoe we can avoid blowing up under those
circumstances oh that's a child I don't
want to blow up I'm being stepped on by
an animal okay I'm not going to blow up
now that is an autonomous military
technology of just the sort there was a
recent letter signed by a great many
scientists this falls into that that
class and in their urging
devices like that be banned but I give
this as an example of the device which
for which there's a good argument that
if we can deploy that technology it's
more humane it's more targeted and it's
more ethical to do so now that isn't
always the case my point is not that I'm
that's right and we should just go ahead
willy-nilly and develop killer robots my
point is this is a much more subtle area
which requires considerable more thought
and research and we should let the
people who are working on it think
through these problems and make sure
that they understand the kinds of
sensitivities and concerns that we have
as a society about the use and
deployment of these types of
technologies
you